[Música]
não vai ser em inglês
Eita carniça Tu é doida é brincando com
comida
uma separação agendada
e provocações a todo momento
tudo muda quando o passado resolve fazer
uma visita Mas eles estão decididos e
pensando na mesma coisa
nesse ambiente pode ser nosso
[Música]
Ele atirou nele na minha frente quer
dizer na minhas costas
mantém com lápis
eles são treinados para matar e agora
precisam de um treinamento para voltar a
amar tudo isso rodeado de inimigos
fortemente armados e prontos para
eliminar
suas vidas e quem sabe a sua relação
Samuel Jackson
[Música]
nenhum desses está nesse filme
eu deixo o papai ser feliz uma vez no
mês
em breve no meu canal no YouTube